Speaker 1: All right, everybody, final story
of the year of the Republican Civil War and
continuing to see MAGA figures turn on the former
President Donald Trump for a completely mild,
uncontroversial milquetoast support for
getting vaccinated because the vaccines
do a good job of protecting you from serious
illness, hospitalization and death from COVID.
There's a guy named Wayne Allen Root. Wayne
Allen Root. He has been a guest on this program
many times, and some of my interviews with him
have been sort of entertaining. I don't know how
much we ever learned when I would talk to Wayne
Allen Root. But there was definitely significant
entertainment value. This guy has been one of
the biggest MAGA lunatic sycophants for years,
and he is now calling for an intervention
of Donald Trump because of again,
very mild, uncontroversial statements of
support for vaccines from Donald Trump, while
still insisting everybody has their freedom and no
mandates and no mask mandates and all this stuff.
Mild support and weigh now in root has gone
completely bonkers. MAGA sick of sycophant
calls for staging an intervention over Trump's
vax support. Let's take a look at the clip
Speaker 2: for the country, and basically I
talked about it. Every poll is just destroying
Biden. He's winning by a landslide is the most
risk one of the most respected men in the world
more than Biden or the pope. He's made a huge
comeback politically and financially. He just
doubled or tripled his net worth with his
social media company, and I wrote that for a
reason. Alex, you know why? Because I felt it was
important to establish with President Donald Trump
what a huge fan, supporter and friend I am.
So I could then come back with my next column,
which will be next week, which is what I call
the intervention. He needs an intervention
from a friend. Wow. Because he's the greatest
president of my lifetime. I love him. I will
always love him. And when you do that, Chinese
president says George Washington until he did this
fabulous. And I love the guy. I just got married
last month. I'm a newlywed. He sent a letter to
be read at the wedding by going on my honeymoon
to Mar a Lago in March. I've already booked the
honeymoon to Mar a Lago in the suite right next to
President and Mrs. Trump. So I'm a friend. I love
the guy and he's been right on everything. Except
this issue is so horribly wrong on this issue.
And the best way to put it, ironically, is he's
dead wrong because people are dying left and right
in just the last few days. A 58 year old Hollywood
director, super fit, super healthy, wiry, thin,
the guy looked fantastic, dropped dead
of a heart attack. This is the word in
every obituary now suddenly died. They're all
vaccinated and they suddenly died. There he is.
Speaker 1: So this is extremely dangerous
rhetoric, of course. And as we know,
when hundreds of millions of people get an
infection, you know, at this point, what is
the real total number of officially there's two
hundred and eighty five million COVID cases. The
real number is probably at least double that, at
least double that. All sorts of different things
can happen. But the allegation there's a football
player we talked about Monday or Tuesday who died,
believed to be seizure related and immediately
it Oh, it must have been the vaccine. A director
dies. Oh, it must have been the vaccine. This is
extraordinarily, extraordinarily dangerous stuff.
Unproven, unfounded. But most importantly, they're
losing it on Trump for something so minor. These
are these are the things that have triggered
people like Alex Jones and Wayne Allen Root
and others at a bill at an event with Trump and
Bill O'Reilly. I guess now it's two weeks ago,
Trump said the following thing.
Speaker 2: But look, we did something that
was historic. We saved tens of millions of lives
worldwide. We together, all of us. Not me. We
we got a vaccine done. Three vaccines done
and tremendous therapeutics like Regeneron
and other things that have saved a lot of lives.
We got a vaccine done in less than nine months
that we're supposed to take from five to 12 years
because of that vaccine, because of that vaccine.
Millions and millions of people. I think this
would have been the Spanish flu of 1917, where
up to one hundred million people died. This was
going to ravage the country far beyond what it
is right now. Take credit for it. Take credit
for it's a great what we've done is historic.
Don't let them take away. Don't take it away from
ourselves. You're playing that. You're playing
right into their hands when you sort of like,
Oh, the vaccine, if you don't want to take it,
you shouldn't be forced to take it. No mandates.
But take credit because we saved tens of millions
of lives. Take credit. Don't let them take
that away from you. OK, so the president made.
Do you agree with that right? Both the president
and I are vaccinated. Do you get the booster?
Yes, I got it too. OK, so on da
da da da da DA Nang, and that's
always a very tiny group of so uncontroversial.
Speaker 1: It's just, I'm vaccinated, I'm boosted.
It's an accomplishment. It's good and the crowd
is booing and people are turning on Trump. Then
with Candace Owens, Candace Owens
trying to do her anti-vax stuff
and Trump saying, Well, hold on. The
vaccines are good. The people mostly
dying are not vaccinated people. Here's that one.
Speaker 4: We see the corruption right. It doesn't
seem like anybody ever pays for the corruption.
And right now, we're seeing corruption life. Even
in terms of big pharma, which is a huge topic on
the minds of mothers, especially, you're seeing
what's happening at these school board meetings.
Where do you stand on these vaccine mandates? And
obviously, I know that you are your pro vaccine
obviously did everything you could to get this
vaccine out. I know it was one of
Speaker 2: the greatest
achievements. We did one for nine
Speaker 4: months and to be able to do
that. But now it's taken a twist, right? It's it's
gotten now we went from this is a good thing and
people should have this option to military men.
You're going to have to resign because you're not
getting this vaccine. Where do you stand on that?
Speaker 2: Well, I stand on forget about the
mandates that people have to have
their freedom. But at the same time,
the vaccine is one of the greatest achievements
of mankind. We would have had in 1917. Remember
the Spanish flu killed perhaps a hundred million
people? Actually, it ended the First World War
because the soldiers was a lot of people don't
know that the soldiers got so sick. It was a
terrible thing. There was no vaccines or would
know anything. I came up with a vaccine with
three vaccines. All are very, very good. Came
up with three of them in less than nine months.
It was supposed to take five to 12 years
Speaker 4: and we should people have died
under COVID this year. By the way, under Joe
Biden, then under you and more people took the
vaccine this year. So people are questioning how
Speaker 2: the vaccine work. But some people
aren't the ones. The ones who get very sick
and go to the hospital are the ones that don't
take the vaccine. But it's still their choice.
And if you take the vaccine, you're protected.
Look, the results of the vaccine are very good,
and if you do get it, it's a very minor form.
People aren't dying when they take the
vaccine, but the masking of children,
Speaker 1: these are such. I mean, even in
that clip, Trump lies. Even in that clip,
Trump lies. These are such basic, uncontroversial
things. And it again shows you the fragility. The
these coalitions are just hanging by a
thread, and they fall apart so quickly as
soon as something even this minor is said.
So that's it for the Civil War. For 2021,
I expect this to play a major role in the midterms
and these coalitions turning on each other could,
at the end of the day, decide who controls the
House and Senate after the 2022 midterm elections.